I was watching on your show the Trump
speech
irregardless of any political
affiliation
you were very immature and very rude
okay I guess that's it there's nothing
else yeah you know there I often will
get emails we'll cover some Trump event
and folks will search around YouTube for
a live stream and sometimes they'll come
across my live stream during which I
comment I give my opinion and my opinion
of trump is quite low uh I don't think
he deserves too much praise and
um as a result people will email me and
say how dare you disrespect the office
of the presidency and we shouldn't talk
about any president you can't be
negative you've got to be what are you
talking about what are you talking about
this is the this this is the United
States of America we if if you want to
talk about decorum and tone your real
concern should be the way in which
Trump's lack of decorum
a completely debased the office of the
presidency